[Music]
all right let's go out to Birmingham
Alabama talk to The Sun Will Come Out
Tomorrow to talk to Annie what's up
Annie hi John how are you so good how
are you I'm doing well thank you for
asking awesome what's
up well my question for you is how can I
talk with my husband about the way that
he communicat with our
children tell me
more he can be um very demeaning at
times and
belittling um especially to my daughter
she uh will be 10 later this month and I
have noticed a change in her
behavior um recently and she's come to
me in confidence and told me that you
know it really hurts her feelings the
way that that he speaks with her um give
me an
example
so um say
she's um trying to make herself a
sandwich
and she makes a mess so instead of uh
telling her okay it's time to clean up
the mess you know don't forget to put
your dishes in the in the dishwasher he
just loses it I can't believe you made
this mess in the kitchen you know why
does it take you so long to clean up
afterward those kinds of things
and he talks to you this way too
otherwise you wouldn't be calling
me he does
yeah wi's enough
enough put your kids aside for a second
when's enough enough for
you
I'm not
sure here's the deal he is dramatically
unhappy with his
life he doesn't like him he doesn't like
how he feels he thought everything in
his life was going to feel
different look
different and if your 10-year-old
daughter made a
sandwich and unlike any 10-year-old on
planet Earth she immediately cleaned up
every crumb
he would criticize how loud she chews he
would criticize the way she walked to
the table she would criticize why did
you use two pieces of ham instead of
just one piece of ham you know how
expensive ham
is because his criticism and grenade
throwing is not about y'all it's about
him and he's not on the
phone you
are what has it been like in the past
when you've said hey stop talking to me
like that
or have
you usually he automatically becomes the
victim and he says things like oh well I
guess I'm just trash or I guess I'm just
not good enough you know for
you man that's a gaslighting
manipulative young man right
there so I'll ask you again how
long how long have youall been married
18 years how long's you been doing
this I would say the
first
eight to 10 years were really
good um and things kind of changed after
we had our daughter the focus shifted
from just he and I to
her you know what that's called it's
called adulthood and
maturity you know you know what I mean
like it's not
like that's everybody's life when you
have kids you have kid number one your
marriage changes it gets
weird your money's different your sex
life is different your communication is
different you got to rebuild something
new and if you don't you go to shame or
embarrassment or I don't like my life
and then you either withdraw from
humanity and and just drink beer and
watch Netflix for the rest of your life
or you just start attacking people in
your
life and making your discomfort and your
dislike for who you have become in your
own life you make that everybody else's
fault well how do I break that cycle for
my children I don't I don't want them to
continue to
live
in feeling like they're not good enough
I know how that feels but I don't want
them to continue into
that you're probably going to have to
have some conversations and take some
actions you that scare you to
death and probably the conversation
starts
with I'm going to be real direct with
you and if you start saying things like
well I guess I'm just the worst and I'm
just trash then you are opting out of
this conversation I need you to stay
present with me don't whine don't
immediately make yourself the drama
victim I want to solve this thing for
our marriage and for our
kids and if he cannot hear that then you
tell
him we're going to have to talk about
next steps until you go get some
professional help because you're unable
to have an adult conversation with your
wife
but you have to be ready for that
conversation because you don't like
discomfort and when he starts his woe is
me that that waks havoc on your body
doesn't
it it does yeah who else did that to you
in your
life my mom yeah
my parents were divorced when I was six
and she left and so my dad raised
me was it your job to make sure mama was
okay it felt that way
yeah was it also your job to put a
smiley face on because Dad was sad a
lot
we had to make things okay even if they
weren't that's that's how it felt that's
not how it felt that's how it
was so I'll just tell you and
six-year-old Annie I'm sorry that you
were responsible for that because that
wasn't your
job whether they stayed married or got
divorced it was your parents job to take
care of their emotions and their
happiness and their grief and their
heartbreak that was never your
job
in the same way your 10-year-old
daughter feels like she has to walk on
eggshells with her dad and that her
actions are being scrutinized under a
microscope and she has to perform for
him that's not her job
either and you know this this is why you
called but I'm going to say it out loud
anyway your kids are desperate for an
adult in their life who loves them to
step in between this
madness
and it may be that that what I the the
like the conversation prompt I gave you
a minute ago that may be too
much it may be a matter of you sitting
down with your husband saying you have
done this to me for 10 years and I'm
watching you do this to your kids this
ends now and you can go down the woe is
me I'm just trash and that's stupid
that's a cowardly way to bow out of a
hard conversation you can do that and if
you walk away from this table then
you're choosing to walk away from this
house for 30 days while we figure out
what's
next or you can stay engaged and we can
figure this thing
out I think at this point you are closer
to the edge of this marriage than you
want to say out loud is that
true I felt that way for a while yeah do
you have somebody
else no okay no I love my husband
implicitly I know but you also are
coming around to understand that you
don't deserve this and your kids don't
deserve
this and your husband either a lacks the
tools every time he reaches in his
toolkit it's empty and so he just goes
to dragging the rest of y'all
down and counseling they call it there
there's the one up position which is the
screaming and yelling and the how dare
you and there's the one down position
which is the well I guess that I'm just
the worst ever I guess we'll just go
have that food I just won't eat that's
fine that's a power play
too and like you mentioned usually it's
moms who do that but it happens with
husbands too especially
increasingly but you have to have a
confrontation is what I'm telling you
are you safe to do that will he hit you
no he's never been abusive not
physically okay will he scream and cuss
and yell at
you you may
okay I think you preface the
conversation with we're going to have a
hard conversation and if if you scream
and yell you're out I want you to
go can you have an adult conversation
with your adult
wife role play that with me if you were
to say that to him what was his what
would his response be you've been with
him 20 years you know what he'll
say what do you mean we need to have a
conversation about what I thought
everything was fine it's not fine and I
need you to sit down and listen very
carefully to what I'm about to tell you
and I don't want you to start defending
yourself I want you to finally listen to
the words I'm going to say can you do
that what would he
say he's such a wild card I don't know
okay I don't sometimes it would be okay
I listen and sometimes it would be well
you know I've been at work all day and I
don't know what this nonsense is about
cool I've been working
too if right now is not a good time you
tell me when it is but it needs to be
within 24
hours and if he gets up and won't have
the conversation you can be very clear
then we're going to have this with a
therapist or we're going to have this
with an attorney you get to pick
and here's what we're
doing if you told me you were unsafe or
that you were vulnerable that he had a
chance to hurt you I would not recommend
this but here's what we're doing we're
shaking the tree
here he needs to know that his little
pity party wo is me I'm just the that is
that that that game is
over you're not
going to talk to my kids you're not
going to make my children fearful in
their own home period you've been doing
it to me for 10 years it ends
now and my hope is your resolve will be
so
clear that he'll stand up a little
straighter and listen to
you or when he starts his woe is me
stuff you say nope we're stopping that
right now are you going to continue to
listen are you going to make yourself a
victim in this
conversation
or well I'm guess I'm just trash you're
allowed to talk to yourself that way I
would never talk to somebody that way
that's a distraction let's get back
to and you may need Annie you may need
to go sit with a professional counselor
and practice this
conversation and you've gotten real
quiet am I scaring you is this whole
idea scaring you or are you feeling
empowered I'm feeling like I need to to
find that strength I don't know if I
possess it but I want to I think you
do I think you
do I also
understand and I've been there too where
I wanted somebody else in the room with
us I wanted a counselor there I wanted a
professional or a pastor I wanted
somebody in the room to make sure a I
was saying things the right way and B
making sure that the whole conversation
stayed on the track stay on stayed on
the
rails when I find myself unable to feel
like I have the strength I always write
it down that way I can go through
multiple drafts and I can be very clear
about what I want to say I read it out
loud and I will sometimes have somebody
else with
me does that work for you I think that
could be the difference between being
able to do it and not okay
I think that's very fair I also am not a
huge fan of not a huge fan of the
surprise
attack I like adults to act like
adults right and so you and me are going
to a
meeting well I've been working all day
I'm tired I Ain going to some stupid
meeting your marriage is at risk I need
you to come to this meeting with me what
what do you mean my marriage at risk I
thought it was fine it's not fine I need
you to come to this meeting I've
arranged child care for our kids it's at
6:00 I need you to be
there and we're not negotiating we're
not having multiple like rounds of this
whoa whoa whoa whoa I've said what I
need to say I'll say the rest of it at
this
meeting can you do
that I think I can okay and if he wants
to call I'd love to talk to
him okay he probably won't but I'd love
to talk to him
too but I'll say this
again and I don't say this to pile on I
say this because you're the
adult your daughter came to you and said
Mom help
me and she's watching and experiencing
your response in real
time and six-year-old
Annie is also asking asking you how long
are we going to do
this and I think it's time to set her
free
too I think you have the strength in
fact I know you
do make a very clear plan and get
somebody else that's going to be in the
room with you and maybe it's a couple
that you all trust maybe it's another
man that you trust it's friends with
your husband it could be any any you
decide who that
is
but your kids deserve peace in their own
home and you do
too and quite frankly so does your
husband call me back
anytime um I'm really interested to see
how this one plays out so holler back at
me after youall have this
meeting we'll be thinking about
you